foreign
law have been married for over 50 years
they just kind of appear to have it all
this however is not the same behind
closed doors and then a couple weeks ago
they came over and I saw she had a huge
bruise that was like a band around her
arm right above her elbow you have to do
so okay so that ship has sailed
[Music]
what's up what's up this is John with
the Dr John delone show so glad that
you're with us and I hope you're having
a great week hope your day is good hope
you woke up and it is chilly and it's
beautiful the sun is shining wherever
you happen to be and if you happen to be
in a place where the sun is not shining
I'm sorry check it off go outside and
walk in the snow or the rain or
whatever's going on
um if you want to be on this show you
want to talk about your marriage talk
about
um raising kids talk about dating
somebody trying to figure out what's
what's coming next if you want to talk
about your mental health and your ADHD
and your anxiety your depression
whatever's going on give me a buzz uh we
want you to be on the show go to John
deloney.com ask a-s-k and um fill out
the form leave it there and uh we'll get
back in touch with you and if you've
been a long time listener thank you so
much for riding with us for so long we
have this wild little gang here we've
increased from 17 listeners we're up to
like 33 now on a regular basis which is
so fun
don't forget leave your five star
reviews please hit the Subscribe button
please and um I'm just just know that me
and my family the gang back here we're
so grateful for your support
um it's because of you guys that we have
the greatest mental health podcast ever
so glad so glad all right
um let's go to no there's nobody on the
on the board
because it's time for your favorite
thing lightning round
it's such like leather pants like foot
up on the monitor just like thrusting
Rock jams good gosh is that your music
Joe
that was Ben's incredible incredible all
right cool so for those that don't know
this is where we have 10 questions that
John has not seen
and I will ask him the question and he
has one minute to give us a brief answer
and then we move on to the next one and
this is your favorite they are because
you don't know and I could I can't say
my name in a minute so yeah and so this
is one of my favorite things that we do
which is why we do it more often now all
right let's dance all right so just so
this one is on all of these questions
are around holiday anxiety that our
listeners sent in when we asked you know
what are your issues around holidays
um and these are the ten that we picked
okay all right let's let's sing and
dance question number one do I have to
buy my friends gifts at Christmas I
can't afford it but I don't want to look
like a cheapskate no
you will only feel anxious if you let me
say it this way you you're gonna feel
anxious either way you're only going to
poison your relationships if you do
something that you can't otherwise
afford that is going to put you in a
less safe position so here's the right
way you're feeling anxious about it I
don't I don't want to feel like a
cheapskate cool go directly through that
storm let your friends know hey guys
this is a tough year financially for me
so I'm not doing gifts this year I'm
gonna do whatever I'm gonna write you
all a song I am going to sing your
favorite song and record it and y'all
we're all going to watch it whatever
cheesy I don't care whatever's coming up
I'm gonna write you a letter and let you
know how much I love you but this year I
can't do gifts and let it be choose
guilt over resentment choose the guilt
of not having a gift over the resentment
of buying stuff putting on a credit card
that you can't afford and it's gonna
cost you hell to pay weeks and months
down the road
look at that slit in there awesome all
right
how do you do holidays with your family
and in-laws when everyone lives in the
same city how do I live Without You nope
Time started already here's what you do
direct clear wonderful boundaries very
strict hey on Christmas morning we're
going to do uh until two o'clock just
our family just us no one else is going
to come over we're not going to go
anywhere we're just going to have our
own little time together we're gonna
have breakfast we're gonna get up we're
going to open presents on our own and
then we will go about whatever
um what nights are we going to get
together be very specific put on a
calendar and hold everybody to it let
everybody know hey don't just we're not
just gonna have showing up at our house
we're gonna make sure the kids are still
going through their sleep routine we're
still going to have bad times we're not
going to just poison our kids with all
the sugar we're gonna leave that to a
couple of days boundaries boundaries
boundaries and I have found in my
personal life and with those I work with
Clarity on the front end saves Decades
of Heartache on the back end
awesome all right
how do I have conversations with my
family at the holidays when we are
politically divided don't don't say this
this magic phrase we are not talking
about politics and if anyone starts
talking about politics I will say I
don't want to talk about politics and if
they continue
you are asking me to leave and I will be
happy to oblige you
end of statement in my house we all have
different political beliefs some
radically different than others and it
makes for a fun Sport and it makes for
awful holiday time so every year we send
out a note uh email just a reminder no
politics and so we can all go back point
back to the email with somebody's like
well you know what's happening in hey
we're not doing that we already set the
boundaries no politics all right all
right all right and hey somebody turned
the news on no no no no no news why
would you do that why would you choose
to be like you know what I'm just gonna
take crap in the middle living room
don't do that no news no news
all right we are just flying through
these look at you
when I see my family at the holidays how
do I feel the intrusive questions like
when are you going to find a husband
[Laughter]
oh boy
directly right on the nose if somebody
has if somebody has the nerve to walk
out to me like so when are you gonna
find a husband
I would just say when a husband Finds Me
or when one shows up
or I don't know how's your marriage
going it doesn't look too great like
just slap it up flip it and reverse it
uh but those inch here's the deal most
people who ask those intrusive questions
are trying to show you that they love
you and just trying to invite you into
something maybe you didn't maybe you
didn't realize how great it is being
married and you thought just being
lonely and single was so wonderful they
might be trying to help so I'm gonna let
that roll off my back and if they keep
doing it say hey I'm not really
interested in talking about my dating
failures right now or I'm not interested
in talking about how much I love being
single right now uh let's talk about
other stuff
all right the next one is a two-parter
when is it acceptable to start listening
to Christmas music and then what is the
worst Christmas song ever
oh my gosh what a great question
I think it is
um morally and should be legally
um
what's the right word I think it's
immoral and it should be illegal let me
say it that way to listen to Christmas
music before
the Friday after Thanksgiving I know
some people who hate babies and uh hate
love and joy start on November 1 and
those people should be removed from
society they should be they should be
removed from society and no question the
worst Christmas song Jenna's like dying
in there because she listens to
Christmas music year round I used to
have a buddy that I worked with named
Kevin Claypool he and Kevin I love it he
listened to Chris music all the time
although he loved it he loved it he
loved it he loved it man and I loved how
much he loved it I just think it's
immoral and
the worst Christmas Song Ever by far
Little Drummer Boy if somebody starts
playing a Little Drummer Boy
no no no that's all I'm gonna say about
that can I just say real quick here we
go it brings me joy so if I want
Christmas toy on November 1st dang it
I'm gonna have Christmas Joy November
1st I just think you should find joy and
other things that are more profitable
for Humanity that's all
that's all
Wendy what about you when do you start
listening to it
um not till after Thanksgiving because
you're a human yeah and you care about
America Joe when do you start
um well I guess around Thanksgiving I'm
old school
I appreciate that and you're wearing an
Alabama hat and I usually wouldn't take
your opinion seriously but I do now
because our opinions aligned so humble
all right on to the next on to the next
how do we do Santa with our kids while
still teaching them that Jesus's birth
is the priority
I think that's just a false dichotomy
it's not an either or
um Santa is a fun and I get this a lot
like you tell us say you don't lie to
your kids but let's tell them about
Santa light no it's participating in fun
like that that's like uh jumping out and
wearing a costume and scary like having
fun like Boo gotcha it's part of a
cultural story it's part of a cultural
myth that we're all a part of
um and some people consider the Jesus
story that too right if you full fully
believe in the Jesus story that has a
sense of reverence a sense of worship a
sense of awe and wonder the Santa that's
just fun it's just having fun and people
like my kid finds out they're gonna
think I'm a liar no they're not they're
gonna know that you participated in a
fun like man we were enjoying your
childhood as much as possible
um so I would hold they're not an either
or proposition like the birth of Jesus
in your home if that means the world to
you it's important in my house if it
means the world to you great have some
reverence around it and dude do
Christmas talk about Santa Claus do the
whole nine yards have fun with it
awesome
what is the best way to approach the
first holiday season after a loved one
has passed away
oh that's good
um I
really believe in getting Upstream as
much as possible with that one ask your
ask your family members how do we want
the best honor so and so during the
holidays
usually people don't have that
conversation and so there's a big gap
and everybody feels that Gap this
elephant just walks in the living room
and Parks right in the middle of the
living room and it's it just adds it's
like a um a tractor beam for all the joy
in the room it just sucks it out of the
room so
send an email around to everybody hey
grandma died hey dad passed away this is
our first Christmas without dad I would
like all of us to
um write down on a piece of paper our
favorite memory of dad and Christmas and
we're all gonna go around a room and
read it and we might all weep
we might all bust a gut laughing we
might get really silent but you're not
gonna avoid that weight that that grief
that missing him by ignoring it by by
pretending she didn't exist so get
Upstream ask everybody how we want to
honor this person how we want what we're
going to do and then everybody
participate in it and my promise to you
is you'll feel it you'll feel it but it
will also add a sense of connectivity to
the entire Gathering
awesome all right I don't want to spend
the holidays with my family how do I
tell them without feeling guilty and
then how do I tell my kids
um you probably can't your first time
around do it without feeling guilty
um maybe your second third or fourth
time and Dave Ramsey my buddy likes to
say uh
parents are often travel agents for
guilt trips right so you might say it
and they're like oh I'm gonna make you
feel guilty I'm just gonna beat you
that's just part of of putting at
boundaries is often often is feeling
guilty so get over that part
um and what was the second part of that
so how do you tell your family and then
how do you tell your kids that we're not
going to be seeing you know we told our
family this year was
um I'm coming off a wild travel season
the we are still adjusting to having a
middle school right now a first grader
and the new year like heading into the
new year is going to be wild and I've
got a book deadline which makes me holy
unfun to be around and so this
particular Christmas we're not going to
be traveling we're going to stay at home
and we're not going to
um we're not going to have people
staying at our house this year and so I
was just pretty direct but really the
problem the issues if you will they're
all me Centric I'm not going to be a
good Host this year because I've got so
much going on and I want to be a good
Steward of my time and my family and my
rest and that means that the best way I
can love you is by telling you this
isn't a great year and by the way all my
family went oh thank God that'd be so
great to have a year off and so
everybody was glad that I put the
boundary out there
why are family and holiday traditions
important for kids
oh that's such a great question we live
in a culture that has pulled the string
on every tradition
we have this idea that if it's not
Innovative and new it's somehow A Relic
in its trash and we are paying the price
culturally for unwinding all of our
cultural narratives that bind us
together there are some that need to go
some filled with hate and evil those
gotta go but filling everything out is
no bueno because it it leaves you
anchorless with your family with your
community with your traditions and so
giving kids anchor points giving them
memory points if you will core memories
right from the movie Inside Out giving
them those moments every year is Rando
as it is I make sure that one of my kids
I pick them up and we put the star on
top of the tree it's a tradition my mom
and my son watch some movie I forgot
what it is they watch me every year they
don't even like the movie anymore but my
son's like it's tradition it's what we
do and it just becomes this Anchor Point
and it becomes a story he's going to
tell at her funeral right the star thing
is going to be a core memory that my
kids remember dad trying to pick up his
humongous 13 year old son and wheeled
him over not knocked the whole tree over
those make important memories and so
give your kids the gift of tradition
give your kids the gift of recurring
memories and recurring actions that they
can anchor to as they move on to their
life
last one and this is kind of connected
to that one what your favorite Christmas
tradition from your childhood
and I just
um
all my family very similar to an earlier
question we all lived in the same city
and we all lived in Houston
um except for my Aunt Jane and and Uncle
Tom they would come in but we all lived
in the same city but Houston's so big
it's an hour apart and so we never saw
each other and so every Christmas Eve we
got together and all hung out for a few
hours a few awkward fun good hours I
loved it that was my favorite and even
into college and into
um when I was married for the first
decade or so we never missed it we
always went back
um and then I talked about this on a
previous show but the punk rock show
third foot fall every Christmas we went
um me and one or two of my buddies and
then turned into my wife came with me
but that was just a fun Gathering of
people many people who that was their
Christmas celebration and it was fun to
get there and just cut loose and sing
some songs and be a little Rowdy be a
little crass and
go home and plan for the new year
that's it awesome
you nailed it I wish all these were this
this not easy but
this simple yeah you really nailed this
one I feel like my mom could have sent
most of these in
maybe she did
none of my family does all right that's
fantastic all right hey
does lightning round that was a
lightning round we'll be right back
hey what's up deloney here I know I know
it's the holidays you're super busy and
between all the decorating Christmas
trees and Christmas parties and your
friends drinking too much eggnog family
visits so many family visits it's so
easy to skimp on sleep don't fall into
that trap my friends you've got to take
care of yourself and your mental health
during the holidays and that means
prioritizing sleep sleep is one of the
best things you can do for your mental
health any time of year but especially
right now and for me getting deep
restorative sleep starts with a good
mattress and that's why my family sleeps
on dream Cloud mattresses and right now
dream cloud is running an unbelievable
offer exclusively for my listeners get
25 off any mattress 599 dollars in
accessories that's pillows a mattress
protector and luxury sheets plus an
additional 50 cash discount when you use
promo code deloni so go to
dreamcloudsleep.com
or dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo
code deloni to get your new mattress
today
all right we are back let's go to Maddie
in Omaha what's up Maddie
hi Mr Dawn Delaney thank you for taking
my call you got it what's up
um okay if you don't mind I wrote
everything down because I didn't want to
mess this up
um so good I appreciate you doing that
because I should probably do that more
all right go for it you need to so um
okay so my mother and father-in-law have
been married for over 50 years they're
in their 70s if you ask anyone to tell
you that they are just the nicest people
you'll ever meet always smiling working
hard they had four kids and now loads of
grandkids
um they just kind of appear to have it
all uh it's this however is not the same
behind closed doors
I don't know the extent of it but I fear
that it gets pretty bad and I don't want
to be right but I don't want to stir the
pot if I'm wrong
um since marrying my husband 20 years
ago their son my mother-in-law has tried
to run away driving several states away
even getting a different phone
she has also tried to end her life but
was found in time taken to the hospital
nobody outside of the immediate family
knows about that
um I overheard him yelling at her one
time when he didn't know that I was in
the house and she was silent the entire
time and as soon as he saw me he stopped
um a couple years ago I noticed she had
bruising around her eye
that she tried to cover up with makeup
and when I asked her about it she gave a
strange explanation but I just thought
well it must be possible so I let it go
and then a couple weeks ago they came
over and I saw she had a huge bruise
that was like a band around her arm
right above her elbow and it looked like
she tried to cover it up with makeup and
I asked her about what happened
and she got really flustered as if she
was like searching for an answer and she
just said she fell and that she bruises
easily
but it didn't make sense because it was
a band around her arm
um my question is questions are what if
I'm wrong and what if I'm not and if I'm
not wrong but I say something and she
doesn't want to do anything about it
they've been married for 50 years you
know that
like I just don't I don't know the steps
to take
yeah thank you for
thank you for being brave and and
um writing all that out you know it's
hard to put down on paper because you
look at it and all of a sudden your
heart starts beating like I gotta do
something right
um my big first question is well let me
just say this you have to do something
okay so that ship has sailed and now
we're going to figure out what that is
um
your husband lived with this he knows
why is he avoidant or doesn't want to
get involved
I've brought it up several times and I
feel like
they kind of try to keep everything
seeming that perfect happy life even for
their kids and grandkids and so
I think he just fears messing all that
up so his mom's about his mom's about to
be dead
all right
like so this little fear of I just don't
want to ruffle feathers moms you're
about to go to a funeral
right that was wholly preventable
that's what I fear and so I look at
these things behavior is a language
so when somebody's running away somebody
thinks in their mind I would rather not
be here at all
than be in this
that is somebody yelling as loud as they
can but without the words
help
great and I'm disappointed in in their
kids
and somebody's got to do something
someone's got to step up somehow okay as
far as
um three of their kids don't live
anywhere near yeah but but they they
know they grew up in this house this
doesn't just happen
that's what I wonder but yeah I don't I
don't know if things changed after
everyone moved out or okay let me ask
you this did it was was heard was your
father-in-law rough on your husband
growing up
he was strict in rules in iron hand but
he didn't
he wasn't that physically abusive like
my husband can point out one time that
his dad did something
what about the has your husband ever
told you about times he hit mom
no never that's why that's why it's
confusing to me is because I I always
thought well they would know something
and but I mean usually it was just a
bunch of yelling and
but he never really mentions physical
stuff which is why I fear that I'm Maybe
I'm Wrong in reading into things
so here's my philosophy as always
and it My Philosophy is very biased
because I've been on the other side of
this and I've been wrong
so when it comes to perceptions of abuse
it comes perceptions of suicidal
ideation
I have made the choice in my life that
I'm gonna err on the side of asking too
many questions and I'm turning on too
many lights then not doing enough
okay that's just the choice I've made
you don't have to make that same choice
um what I would do if I'm in your
situation is I would tell my husband
I have seen bruises on under her eyes
I've seen bruises on her body that she's
trying to cover up and when I ask her
about it as a woman I know she's not
telling me the truth
I know she's covering for somebody
and so I'm going to ask her directly are
you safe
and I would y'all live in the same town
yes me and my husband live in the same
time okay
um
I would take her to breakfast or I'd
take her to lunch and I would say I'm
gonna be very direct with you because I
love you
and I consider you a mom almost as close
as my real mom
and
I have a woman's intuition that you're
not okay
tried to run away you tried to die by
Suicide you've got bruises when you come
over to my house that you're covering up
are you safe
are you okay
and you are very very right she might
say I'm 50 years in that's just him if I
just was quieter then he wouldn't get so
angry that's how those
she's a grown-up she can make that
choice at some point it becomes elder
abuse
and I know there's some different Power
hierarchies in yada yada
if somebody is unable to take care of
themself and they are being abused I'm
gonna let somebody know
and at the end of the day this this
might end with you calling the police if
you tell her hey the next time I see
bruises on you
I'm calling somebody
okay right and it might be you call it
for a welfare check and she lies to the
police officer she lies to the social
worker and she she does that
but at least you will have sent a
message to everybody involved is I'm
watching and I love you seemingly more
than anybody else in this in this fear
and also also be open to being
completely wrong
okay
okay she might tell you no I I I know
how this looks and it's not what you
think it is okay
um but your guts tell you something's up
don't they
yes absolutely okay
uh
uh here's here's what other siblings
into it or like the spoken to my husband
but I haven't talked with any of his
siblings no I would make this a very
personal
woman-to-woman conversation
um I've had conversations with grown men
before
where we've just gone out to lunch or
gonna grab a drink or something and I've
said hey
um this isn't technically my business
but I'm choosing to insert myself into
this
if you talk to
so and so again like that we're gonna
have a problem
or I'm not gonna bring me and my kids
and my family around this I love you and
I like being your friend like hanging
out you can't talk to women like that
not in my presence not presents of my
kids
and if this goes down she's welcome to
come stay with me you are not I've had
that conversation a few times and it
hasn't been awkward because a I had a
relationship with these folks and I
wasn't trying to like be like yeah bro
we're gonna fight out in the park I had
nothing to do with that
just had to do with hey this is right
and I've had people do that for me
right like hey John like what you're
doing right now is not right it's not
who you want to be it's not how you say
you are as our friend group it's not who
uh We've agreed we're gonna be this easy
to stop now does that make sense so I've
had people reach out and tell me they
love me in that way and so that's that's
all you're doing here
it's a private conversation
and so if I if if I have this especially
discuss with her
and she kind of just laughed it off
because I'm going to kind of picture her
doing like is that pretty much that's
all I could do and I back off no I think
I think you let her know
um
I understand this is scary and if you've
lived with this for a long long time
um I I I understand how big of a deal
this is
I need you to hear me say if I see
bruises on you again
um I'm gonna call somebody
okay if you want me to go with you to
make a report if you want me to go with
you to sit down and tell your husband
you're no longer allowed to hit me
anymore
I'll go with you
um our your husband her son will come
with us too
so it's the after it's the I see what's
going on here I love you I'm with you
and
here's what I'm going to do next
okay that makes sense all right
she might not be able to tell you when
it happens again
but she might show up if she knows
you're gonna call
she might show up that very next morning
after she gets hit the next time
and let you see that bruise
and that's her screaming help
with words she doesn't know how to say
does that make sense
yes absolutely
um
that phone call to the police is not a
he's beating her up whatever it is hey
I've got concerns and I feel like I
would sleep I'm just gonna sleep better
knowing that I made the call and that I
reached out on behalf of somebody that I
care about
um
my mother-in-law keeps coming to the
house with bruises I've been in the
house where there's a rage screaming
um I'm fearful that she's being abused
I've talked to her about it she said she
said no no it's okay
um something's not right I would like
y'all to do a welfare check on her
and that way you know I'm not throwing
grenades at him I'm not this is purely
on me this is what I'm seeing this is
what I'm feeling and my intuition says
something frightening is going on and by
the way let's remember this intuition is
simply your body remembering
uh what it has seen before
have you seen this before
uh yes yep that's what intuition is
okay
well I appreciate it because I just felt
lost I felt like I was supposed to go
with my husband that when he didn't
really when he kind of brushed it off I
didn't really know where to go from
there so yeah and it it's maybe that he
truly doesn't know it may be that he
didn't really take it seriously he may
be he may know
oh oh Maddie if we open this if we open
this box it's world war three
and I would continue to remember y'all
are about to go to a funeral
okay all right well thank you is that
cool
yeah thank you so much for caring and
loving those in your community
and to everybody listening who's going
like oh my gosh you need to mind her own
business whatever
look around
look around
this is the culture we've got with that
kind of attitude
if somebody thinks I'm beating up my
wife I hope to God they will step in
front of me and call me on it
there's a great story that we did a few
um man it's maybe six or seven months
ago it was a great story where
um a guy was walking into a grocery
store and his was carrying his daughter
over his back and she was kicking and
screaming and hollering or no carry him
out of a store
and she was kicking screaming and a man
walking into the store in the parking
lot stopped and said honey are you okay
are you safe
and she's like no no turns out I don't
remember what the exactly like she
wanted to buy something in the store and
she threw a temper tantrum and Dad's
like we're getting out of here
but that Dad who was carrying his
daughter out said Thank God somebody in
the parking lot stopped and saw a
screaming kid to make sure everything
was okay
[Music]
that's the community that we need with
one another man
we're not not being involved like not
being involved putting our heads down
and walking it's not helping man it's
not helping
and I don't want a whole bunch of people
going to a funeral that was they don't
need to be going to
Step Up Step Up have the hard
conversation
your community needs you we'll be right
back
deloney here and I've got a word from
this episode's sponsor betterhelp let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help us
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist at under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
all right we are back let's take before
you move on I have a question
in that last call you said intuition is
your body remembering what it seemed
before can you talk a little bit about
that
yeah
um we often you hear me talk about alarm
systems like our body puts GPS pins and
things that it remembers and it sees and
then it sets the alarm off later that's
intuition and we often think intuitions
like this mystical
space cadeti thing it's like oh I'm in
touch with my spiritual it might be
but more than likely your body has seen
that before and so it's responding to
something it's seen before
it's a that's why I told her hey you got
to say something and be be open to being
wrong because sometimes that GPS system
every guy with dark hair is not scary
right and every time he comes in here I
just feel a sense of not good but it's
important to
um look at uh answer those feelings to
feel them and then demand evidence from
them is this true right but intuition is
simply your body saying I remember this
this is not okay and it starts swelling
up the anxiety it starts swelling up the
heart rate it starts that discomfort
um it's when I go into a place and my
wife says we need to go right now
I used to just laugh and roll my eyes
and now I've learned like she's her body
has seen this story before it's time to
go and it might be that you're about to
be an idiot and say something stupid or
you're gonna get in a fight you're gonna
do something dumb something to go
um yeah so does that ring true in your
in your life
oh definitely yeah yeah because I always
think of that women's intuition could it
also be something maybe not that we've
seen before but we've you've read about
heard about well and that that's the
problem with media that's is it puts
stories into our bodies and our bodies
often can't distinguish whether you
listen to enough murder podcast you're
gonna start looking over your shoulder
right it just is it just is you watch
enough Law and Order SVU every guy
walking hand in hand with a little girl
in a grocery store is probably molester
right and so I do think media plays a
like a damning role in shifting our
bodies like our body's like oh I
remember that guy I remember that guy
that never even happened right it was
just fiction
um but yes I do think that's that
happens okay I had a weird situation at
the grocery store a couple weeks ago
with a guy that just he appeared on
every aisle
it was just something creepy about him
and then when I walked out he walked out
behind me and was standing
no he like had abandoned his card it was
gone and it was just one of those
something felt weird and I've never had
that happen before but something told me
it was like
you know it's time to leave but you may
have had somebody
do that when you were nine and they were
10 and they kept showing up at the dance
and you were just like ah just you know
what I mean
um or yeah you may have watched one too
many horror movies allegedly
I don't know what you're talking about
yeah uh it goes back to you'll say
listen to your bodies listen to your
bodies man
um and one of I think our great life
lessons is how can I better hear what my
body's trying to tell me and I think
that's a good exercise for all of us all
right let's go to gym across the
northern border in Calgary what's up Jim
hey how's it going good man how are you
um I'm not too bad not too bad uh funny
but it's an old day here today so
that's so good man oh hey can I just
tell you your accent brings me joy makes
me happy
I have an accent
well I'm a Texan so we're basically on
the other side of Earth and I get the
same thing like man we love your Texas
accent I'm like I don't have an accent I
guess definitely I do so yeah it's
fantastic so hey so what's up man
ah well
um I used to go I'm looking to try and
I've been trying to think of ways I've
been trying to
reconnect with my wife I have not been
able to I'm looking for ways to try and
reconnect my life it's just
it's just been uh
just been going south for quite a long
time now it's uh we uh
we haven't really been all that close
we've been not basically roommates for
for years
um when's the last time you all had
sexual intimacy
probably over three years ago
wow
yeah
[Applause]
um
part of that part of that is uh that I
am basically Working Day and Night
literally like not even it's not
figurative it's literally like I drive
Courier Service uh from 10 at night till
five in the morning and then I work uh
and I work uh uh Construction in the
daytime until about up to four pm
sometimes 5 p.m go to sleep and so I'm
lucky to get that sport is a six hour
sleep a day a night whatever what what
are you what are you running from
what am I running from yeah uh
I don't know if I'm running from
anything maybe uh the bill collector
that's about it I mean that's like are
you yeah are you running from Financial
insecurity are you in a season where
you're trying to earn a bunch of money
to get your guys solvent because you're
scared financially or have y'all created
I I I'd say that's accurate yeah that's
uh yeah
um we uh we I I I'm self-employed okay
so uh
I read my own exterior business and uh
things are going quite well for for
quite a while there and we were doing
really good we were like and we were
just like a mom and pop
uh shop right uh sure we just do it all
on our own like I did a lot of it on my
own I I actually built up to about uh
four crews for a while and that was
going good for a while we were looking
good and then all of a sudden the
recession hit here in 2015 and
everything just went South all at once
and
and uh yeah it's uh
just you know with the good graces of
God and friends that we were able to
hold on to our home and things like that
and and it just you know and and I've
been uh like there's the people have
been all they've been saying you know
why don't you just go bankrupt it's like
no I
I don't want to do that you know I I
they're my bills I want to pay them you
know that's that's Noble and good um
is that when your marriage took a turn
um foreign
yeah it would be short right in that
right in around that time
they're
there's a lot of uh oh geez oh God my if
you want to go back into my my past life
like it's
it's like a person would probably make a
career on me you know um
I'm just with a lot of different uh a
lot of different things that have gone
on in the past uh are you talking about
in the past in your marriage
this is my third marriage so
uh my my first marriage was just a
complete disaster a very young uh
very young uh wife got pregnant and I
wanted to be around my daughter and
so but that just fell apart within five
years and
then my second marriage my wife just
walked out so
um that that one didn't go very well I
mean it was a it was uh my wife now and
and uh we've been together going on now
I guess it'd be 24 years now but we've
only been married uh nine so and she
she's she's left you too Jim
she stays she she left it too she stays
in the house with you
but y'all aren't married we're not even
in the same room you know so
so and part of part of what's going on
is that that I think uh what really
really hurts me is like I I I'm I'm
concerned about how this is affecting my
daughter like I'm sure she's not she's
not stupid but she she seems like a
happy child but I just don't know how
it's really affecting her right and like
uh she's my my daughter's like she's my
wife how old is she
12 12. so
your current wife isn't on the phone so
you're the only person I can talk to in
this in this relationship okay is that
fair all right sir yes so if I look back
to the last three relationships you've
been in there's been one common
denominator and that's you
yeah well that's uh trust me that's uh
okay across my mind too all right so
your first one it just fell apart I
don't believe in that relational phrase
It's not that's not a true statement
things don't just fall apart
relationally people stop trying they
start putting their attention into other
things like building a business or
alcohol or
still sleeping around or whatever like
they put their attention other places
and not on the relationship and all like
if you stop changing the oil in your car
it doesn't just fall apart it quits
working because nobody took care of it
right and your second wife just left
right she just said I'm not doing this
your third wife has just parked right
she didn't fight she didn't flee she
just froze this is it this is the life I
got I'm moving into this bedroom and I'm
gonna try to create a world where I can
survive inside of a pocket of whatever
chaos I live in or I'm going to continue
to be a mistress to all these jobs
and imagine her
wondering man what is so unbeautiful and
unsexy about me what is so undesirable
about me that I'm second place to a
courier service
well actually
um
I don't do the two jobs by choice like
because I've uh
discussed with her on the number of
occasions where I don't want to be
working two jobs and because she doesn't
work okay she's she stays at home
um when shy when she was born
um
when my daughter was born she uh
we agreed that she was going to be a
stay-at-home mom
you know and I had no problem with that
things were good at the time you know um
business was going well and all that
um and uh I didn't have a problem with
that you know and we just we thought it
would be better for her to be home with
her mother instead of in daycare or
whatever great babysitters and stuff I
and quite frankly my daughter has never
had a babysitter ever that's probably
not good because that means y'all have
never been on a date
no we haven't yes and she was born
that's not good that's a terrible
statistic my kids have had tons of
babysitters because me and their mom are
always going out
I have
tried that I have made suggestions to go
out uh anytime that we have gone out
it's
with our daughter okay so
um and I love her to death like
there's no daughter
I totally believe that um there's no
question about that but you know there's
I've I've wanted to go out and and do
things like just us go out you know uh
like before before our daughter was born
you know we used to go out dance and
stuff like we're
uh country western dancers so here's the
deal you employed that quite a bit your
wife
has a life has created a world
inside of your marriage that includes
her and her daughter and not you and
this is a pretty common thing that
happens
and
then you create a life financially that
you have to have and one of you just
keeps working and adding jobs and doing
stuff because the data you've received
over the last 15 20 years is you're not
very good at relationships
and you love being a dad but she's just
better than you at it and so the one
thing you are good at is work
and so you say that's the best way I can
support and show my wife and my kid that
I love them is I'm just going to work
more and make sure their needs are taken
care of and there's some nobility to
that
but I promise you
you are working yourself in to an early
early death
oh I know I keep uh mentioning that like
like I said I have brought this up with
her and I've wanted to you know to quit
the night job because it's but I
I mean here's here's how we bring this
up here's how we bring this up
um
we bring this up you too
and I would push pretty hard for a
um babysitter
and I would push pretty hard for a
actually your kid's 12 now it's not
really a babysitter but somebody to come
over and keep your kid or let your kid
go play somebody's house for a weekend
and you and your wife are in desperate
need of some sort of retreat whether
it's four hours or half a day or a
whatever that looks like
do you have a history of yelling getting
fired up getting raged out
on the other end okay so your wife's got
a history
and usually the calm calm one and I'm
usually uh it's it uh wouldn't wouldn't
it like I don't even try to discuss
things anymore like I I basically am
constantly just walking away because
I I I refuse to fight in front of my
daughter for one
I try I try my like I've I came from a
pretty uh pretty rotten uh family like
my family life was uh
pretty violent and abusive and uh and
and actually my wife came from something
similar to that as well uh from what she
tells me it was uh she was abused quite
a bit
so uh
so here's here's what we get here when
we argue it it ends up into a screaming
match well I
I very rarely raise my voice like I I
get angry and I rarely raise my voice
and I I'll say things like
you don't need to yell and then she gets
really loud
exactly oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
um coaching somebody on how they're
angry is usually not the best or the
best strategy
um it usually the best strategy in that
situation is later
to say Hey whenever we're having a
disagreement which everybody in the
relationship is going to have whenever
you raise your voice it reminds me of
being a kid and I shut down my body just
shuts itself down
and so it would be really a gift to me
if when we got into disagreement we
figured out a way to do that calmly or
we wrote each other notes or whatever as
we practice this
um
so earlier I said you were the common
denominator that goes one of two ways
the common denominator being you are the
guy that's really hard to be married
with and all these women are marrying
you and then they're like dude I'm out
of here out of here out of here or
you've heard the old saying that's
actually true we marry our unfinished
business
and it might be that you keep picking
the same partner over and over again
because your body has identified
relationships is something that's
abusive
yeah you know that has crossed my mind
too well and I and you have a little boy
inside of you wondering what it was so
bad about you that your mom talked
screamed at you like that and that Dad
beat the crap out of you whatever
happened and you have a little boy
that's constantly trying to solve it and
you tried it with wife number one and
you tried it with wife number two and
now you're trying it with wife number
three
and your wife's probably marrying her
unfinished business because you look
like a nice stable guy which is a
hundred percent different than what she
grew up with
the only problem is she does not have
the relational tools to be connected to
a calm quiet guy she has relational
tools for war
and you too have to decide I am going to
stop doing relationships as I've done
them my entire life and learn new skills
one of you you I'm gonna speak up more
and I'm going to let my needs be heard
and I'm going to stop committing long
tail suicide in the form of working 20
hours a day for year after year after
year
and your wife's gonna have to learn
every relationship is not a battle in
fact there's a totally different reason
for relationships in its peace
and I've just never experienced that so
I'm gonna have to practice it and learn
it y'all are both gonna have to make
that choice or you're just gonna have
divorce number three and if you're gonna
have divorce number three I'd recommend
sooner rather than later
but this this works with you telling her
I want to love you the best that I can
and I have
grown up with this and I want to do
something different would you be willing
to go with me
and that's going to look like me letting
my needs be heard me getting some sleep
and honoring my body me spending private
time with our relationship with my
daughter
us
rekindling Romance
you making some choices to to learn
different ways of communicating and not
fighting and going to war
because you're talking about two adults
deciding we're going to do everything
different from this point forward and
that's a tall ask it is a hundred
percent doable but both of you have to
be on the same page
I also know this brother
I I can feel it on you
that you think this is going to be a
futile conversation
yeah like I quite often I want to talk
about something and I just
I just figure what's the point all right
so here's what I want you to do you know
what's the point you you're worth the
point
your daughter's worth the point your
marriage is worth the point you still
love that lady your wife is worth it
that's what the point is that's the why
so if I'm you and I know I'm waving in
to you know the entrance to hell I am
going to write this down and write a
letter to to my wife and I'm going to
take her out I'm going to read it to her
and the letter is not going to be filled
with accusations you don't do this and
you don't do this and we haven't had sex
in three years and you don't it's not
going to be that
it's going to start with I miss my wife
I miss you
and I've participated in a marriage
where We've Ended up as roommates and I
miss you and I want to find our way back
to one another
I don't want to to raise a daughter who
thinks this is what marriage looks like
that it's just roommates
I don't want to raise a daughter who
feels like she is responsible for Mom
and Dad's emotional well-being
that she's the center of our household
that everything revolves around her so
much so that my parents haven't had a
date in a decade
because of poor little old me because
she can't handle the weight of your
household she's 12.
so you say what's the point you are man
you get one shot at this little life
dude
so write it down have the hard
conversation and for the first time
maybe in a long time
ask what you need
ask yourself what I need man
what am I willing to do what am I
willing to change what am I willing to
give
and ultimately the end of this
conversation with your wife is an
invitation are you willing to go on this
imitate on this journey with me
where we both learn new ways of
interacting we both heal from our
childhood that both of them are awful
I'm all in if you're all in and it's
going to be bumpy and hard we might just
see a marriage counselor together which
I highly highly advise I don't really
see a way forward for YouTube without it
it'd be great
um
the point is you and your marriage and
your kid you're worth it man
let me know how that conversation goes
I'll be thinking about you because this
one's hard I know because it takes two
to tango man it takes two people to say
yes let's change everything
it only takes one person to say shut up
screw this
get up get get on with your life
and you've got some really hard choices
to make
and I'll be with you along those roads
too man if that's where it ends up
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we are back hey I just gave uh
during the break gave Jim him and his
wife a copy of own your past change your
future if you haven't picked that book
up if you're wondering what do I do next
all right I want to heal this
relationship I got childhood trauma to
heal from I just want my life to be
different
um as you enter in the holiday season
you start thinking about what the New
Year's going to look like it's a great
uh number one bestseller it did well uh
but it continues to do well helping
people figure out okay here's what
happened what am I gonna do next so go
to John deloney.com and pick that up all
right during the break Kelly came in and
dropped these lyrics off I haven't
turned them over yet I'm turning them
over
oh gosh you would
hmm
I don't know if you all know this uh
listening audience
um but part of getting a PhD is you have
to take a class in Latin and you may not
know this but Kelly Daniel in Latin
is uh
it's Latin for the worst the worst
if someone's like oh
that meal is Kelly Daniel that's Latin
for that meal's terrible it's the worst
today's song of the day
is a re Remix by Pentatonix
pentatonic
songs called Little Drummer Boy
the worst Christmas song ever
ever they ran out of lyrics and they
actually sang the snare drum that's how
great this song is
goes like this
come they told me parampa pum pum
a newborn king to see
our finest gifts we bring
harumpa pum pum
hang on to your hats kids get the
kleenex box ready to lay before the king
all right
[Music]
that's terrible it's the world it's the
worst Rudolph the Red-nosed
see you soon
[Music]